thank you very much for joining us we
begin this NewsHour with the latest
efforts to end the eight-year war in
Yemen a delegation from Saudi Arabia has
arrived in the yemeni capital Sana Oman
is mediating the discussions about a
permanent ceasefire the delegations are
expected to hold meetings with houthi
Representatives the talks come after
Saudi Arabia and Iran agreed to restore
diplomatic relations last month as part
of a deal brokered by China on Saturday
Yemen's houthi Rebels and Saudi Arabia
exchange Prisoners the houthis received
13 detainees in exchange for one Saudi
prisoner nearly 400 000 people have been
killed in millions more displaced in the
conflict
well let's get a closer look at the war
in Yemen which began as part of the Arab
Spring of 2011 when President Ali
Abdullah Saleh gave up power to his
deputy after Rising instability and
political divisions houthi Rebels
captured the capital Sana in 2014 and
demanded a new government Saudi Arabia
backs the internationally recognized
government and launched a military
campaign against the houthis in 2016 U.N
sponsored talks between the yemeni
government and Rebels began in Kuwait
but didn't stop the fighting then in
2017 Huffy Rebels believed to be backed
by Iran killed former president Ali
Abdullah Saleh after he broke ties with
the group a year later U.N broke a talks
made progress and last year the warring
sides agreed to a truce which lasted for
six months well let's bring in Al
jazeera's Hashem al-bara to the NewsHour
he's covered the Yemen conflict
extensively Hashem first of all how
significant is this moment and these
talks in Sanaa today
can we expect a breakthrough in this
country it is definitely a defining
moment I've been talking to different
sources particularly from the healthy
delegation in Sanaa and they say that
they can see the prospects of Peace
growing in the region what is happening
as we're speaking in Sana is that the
Saudi delegates along with the omanis
who are brokering the deal along with
the houthis are trying to work out the
modalities of a permanent ceasefire and
you know this time they're trying to
work out all the details particularly
when it comes to the areas where you
still have military confrontations and
they would like to ensure that this is
something that is going to last long now
when the at the same time they will
announce a prisoner exchange between the
houthis and the internationally
recognized government this is going to
be phase one the key access in this are
on one hand Saudi Arabia on the other
hand the herthis who control the
northern part of Yemen right now before
we talk about the next steps you talk
about several phases here and of course
we've seen the prisoner exchange before
we get to the next steps and hurdles
possibly
what made this moment possible to have a
Saudi delegation in Sana after eight
years of a devastating conflict what is
it that led to this moment today
is China Saudi Arabia's reproachment
with Iran brokered by China
does that have a role in what's going on
definitely massive impact on what we see
happening on the ground now in Yemen the
Saudis launched the campaign against the
houthis in 2015 hoping to be able to
bring back the internationally
recognized government to power but then
the campaign turned into a debacle
years later it's been criticized by the
International Community humanitarian
activists have been saying it's about
time to end the conflict in Yemen
there's also this approachment between
the Saudis and the Iranians and you can
clearly see that Crown Prince and prime
minister of Saudi Arabia Mohammed bin
Salman in his vision to move forward
modernize the country needs to invest
more in the country he needs a sense of
permanent stability in the region and
how to remind our viewers that the
drones that targeted on installations in
Saudi Arabia they've been blamed on the
Iranians and the and the houthis and the
I think the Saudis are now willing to
turn that
chapter now they will definitely have to
go back to the Iranians when it comes to
the implementation of the modalities of
every single step of this agreement if
it happens yeah in Yemen now if the
agreement happens what would it look
like are we likely to see a centralized
government in Sanaa again or is it much
more complicated than that are we likely
to see a power sharing agreement between
the houthis and the saudi-backed I don't
think it's going to happen I think it's
going to be a a mammoth task for
everybody because I was just a while ago
talking to a senior healthy official it
was very optimistic on the truth but
when I asked him about power sharing he
said wait because as far as we are
concerned as the health is this is what
we'd like to see happening we would like
the restrictions we posed on us to be
lifted we would like the Embargo to come
to an end with like foreign troops a
reference to the humanity troop stations
in the island of circle to pull out from
the country with like compensation for
the atrocities committed against us and
we would like the International
Community to understand that
is never going to happen again
second condition set by the houthis is
that all the parties have to come to the
houthis and say it has to be a sovereign
independent Yemen with zero influence
from Saudi Arabia or any Gulf nation and
no links whatsoever with the United
States of America I was going to ask you
about the United States where does this
leave the U.S the Americans of course
provided support to the saudi-led
Coalition giving them arms weapons
throughout this eight-year conflict can
the Americans still play a role in
putting a close to this conference I
don't see any leverage to be honest with
you when it comes to Yemen anytime soon
for the simple reason
when you look at the Optics it's the
Saudis doing business with the houthis
in a way or another it's
a health is being now consolidating
their power in the northern part of the
country so from now onwards it's you
have to go back to the healthies for any
deal the health is they have this
position totally anti-American in the
region they say that the biggest problem
with facing the region is to be is
because of the U.S
interference in the region what are they
likely to do the only option left for
the Americans is try to boost the
presence of the internationally
recognized government to be able to gain
some leverage in the future but I have
to say that even the presidential
Council which was appointed last year
doesn't have any control over huge
territory in Yemen now there's another
huge problem which is basically the
southern part of the country which says
now after 2015 we're definitely going to
break away from the north the healthies
are saying Yemen should never break away
yeah interesting and is this also
perhaps the Saudis turning their backs
to the Americans briefly please and also
to the emeritis this they teamed up in
2014 well in 15 to launch this fight
against the healthiest now they walk in
separate ways both each with a different
agenda when it comes and I think this is
likely to further strain ties between
the Saudis and the mrcs in the near
future thank you very much Hashem for
that thank you for your analysis of this
situation in the Yemen